Oh Georgie Georgie wake up okay  what happened you fainted okay let me  start over  my name is Largey I was used to being  invisible no one was paying attention to  what I was doing I read a letter when I  have a crush so intense that I don't  know what else to do  there are five total Peter with the  beautiful eyes Kenny from Camp Lucas  from homecoming John Andrews from Model  UN and Josh the boy next door  oh hey what are you doing nothing nobody  else knows about them can you maybe just  admit that some part of you doesn't want  everything in your life do you fantasy  [Music]  you've got to get out there and show  people who you really are  [Music]  [Music]  magical  let's do this  hey can I talk to you  me yeah look I really appreciate it but  it's never gonna happen I'm sorry what I  think it's really cool that you think I  have Colden specs in my eyes oh my god  the letters are out  you